[Musica]
sono molto contenta di essere qui oggi è
principalmente anche per parlare di un
tema così importante che mi sta
particolarmente a cuore
ho pensato tanto a cosa avrei voluto
dire in questi preziosi 15 minuti e alla
fine ho deciso di raccontarvi una storia
perché alla fine le storie sono sempre
piacevoli da ascoltare e quello che vi
racconto è una storia d'amore è una
storia d'amore non classica non è tra un
uomo una donna non è tra una donna una
donna un uomo un uomo ma è una storia 3
quindi moderna
tra tre soggetti la storia inizia
con la nascita del protagonista che
quindi a un bambino
e inizia proprio il giorno della sua
nascita
apre gli occhi e
si innamora delle prime persone che vede
i suoi genitori
le persone che si prendono cura di lui
per prime prova una sensazione di
trasporto totale di purezza di fluidità
inizia così la sua storia d'amore con
l'altro il nostro bambino cresce si
guarda le manine si rende conto di avere
due mani due piedini delle gambe
queste gambette lo possono portare
vicino alla mensola le manine gli
permettono di toccare questa scatola
piena di luci di musica dei suoni la
televisione e è meravigliato dal suo
corpo non si spiega la magnificenza e la
possibilità di fare tutto quello che
vuole con questo giocattolo che è suo
inizia così la storia d'amore con se
stesso
il nostro bambino cresce e inizia anche
a
sperimentare a conoscere il mondo per la
prima volta nella sua vita arriva
l'autunno e vede le foglie che da verdi
diventano gialle da gialle diventano
rosse è una magia cambiano colore e poi
va al mare per la prima volta e vede
delle onde che danzano all'interno di
questo mare e dei brillantini sopra il
mare che è riflesso della luce del sole
e di nuovo prova quella sensazione di
sentirsi parte di un qualcosa che è più
grande di lui in cui non ci sono
pensieri si sta bene
inizia così la storia d'amore con la sua
casa il nostro bambino cresce diventa un
adulto e si rende conto che l'altro in
realtà non lo capisce è tanto diverso da
lui
invece di sentire quella sensazione di
appartenenza che provava prima sente
proprio distacco
finisce così la sua storia d'amore con
l'altro
si guarda allo specchio
e si rende conto che è un po troppo alto
è un po troppo grosso non è poi così
atletico come vorrebbe essere
finisce in quel momento la sua storia
d'amore con se stesso
continua la sua vita ovviamente a un
adulto per cui corre la mattina corre in
ufficio
poi corre a casa poi corre in palestra
poi core a casa di nuovo e poi esce con
gli amici non ha più il tempo di vedere
le foglie che cambiano colore non ha più
il tempo di vedere le onde che danzano
nel mare
e finisce così la sua storia d'amore con
la sua casa
il nostro ormai adulto continua a
correre lungo la strada della vita a un
certo punto inciampa
inciampa e si siede
nel momento in cui si siede e si ferma
si rende conto che
non sente più l'amore non sente più
quella sensazione di trasporto di juan
sto da dio non la sente più e la cosa
speciale è che in quel preciso momento
in cui lui se ne rende conto in cui
prende consapevolezza di questa
sensazione qualcosa di magico scatta si
riaccende in lui una piccola fiamma
non fa niente si rialza riprende il suo
percorso della vita però non corre più
inizia a camminare
incontra delle persone e si rende conto
che queste persone sono fantastiche
hanno una manualità incredibile sono in
grado di fare delle cose veramente
interessanti si innamora del di nuovo
dell'altro decide allora di supportare
la sua comunità di scegliere di
utilizzare servizi acquistare prodotti
da persone che le recchie realizzano
queste cose all'interno della sua
comunità perché lui ama la sua comunità
si guarda nuovamente allo specchio e
pensa beh non sono poi così male
sono contento della persona che sono
diventato io amo me stesso
decido allora di fare in modo che tutte
le cose le persone i prodotti che
entrano in contatto con me mi facciano
del bene
torna ad amare se stesso
camminando al tempo di vedere le foglie
che cambiano colore al tempo di vedere
il cielo che al tramonto diventa
arancione rosa è di mille sfumature
si rende conto che torna ad amare la sua
casa sente di nuovo che la sensazione
che è veramente indescrivibile di wow io
faccio parte di tutto questo è veramente
speciale
sceglie allora di collaborare di avere
nella sua vita solo prodotti aziende
persone che come lui a mano la sua casa
torna ad amare la sua casa
questa è la mia storia d'amore potrebbe
essere la vostra storia d'amore e dell
amore per l'altro per la comunità
l'amore per se stessi e l'amore per la
nostra casa per il nostro mondo
questo amore questa sensazione mi ha
resa un'imprenditrice che ha deciso di
lavorare solo con aziende che realizzano
nel mio settore
filati
materie prime sostenibili e che vengano
già create pensando al futuro a
biodegradabilità accelerata o che
facciano parte di un economia circolare
ma mi ha fatto decidere di lavorare solo
con aziende che come me amano questa
casa che decidono di utilizzare
energia rinnovabile di riciclare l'acqua
all'interno dei processi nei quali
lavorano e mi ha fatto decidere di
lavorare con aziende che personalmente
possono conoscere con artigiani della
zona il famoso made in italy è fatto
proprio di persone come noi del mio
vicino di casa che vive di
quell'attività
concludo dicendo che se risvegliate il
bambino che c'è in voi lui sa già come
vivere una vita sostenibile e qualunque
scelta che poi andiamo a fare nella
veramente vita molto pratica sarà
dettata da una sensazione di amore per
l'altro per noi stessi e per il nostro
pianeta grazie
[Applauso]